est ce que vous vous souvenez en 2019
asus sortait sa deuxième version de son
smartphone de gimme le asus rog faune de
design hyper léchée vraiment bien rogge
aérodynamique système d'ailleurs l'asus
rog fun ii avait remporté un prix c'est
vous qui lui aviez attribuez vous avez
demandé l'année dernière en fin d'année
de voter pour les meilleurs smartphones
de l'année les prix ont été remis lors
de la grande soirée de la téléphonie
mobile que je co organisé avec mon ami
ariel gomez
[Musique]
et asus avait gagné parce que c'est un
smartphone
c'était un smartphone d'ailleurs c'est
toujours aux smartphones extrêmement
performant extrêmement bon pour le
gaming mais pas que
hélas cette année asus revient en force
avec une nouvelle version de son iphone
c'est le rock band 3 qui est là il est
plutôt là parce que j'ai déjà sorti que
j'utilise mais ça c'est la boîte et je
sais pas si vous êtes prêts mais
l'europe fun 3 va continuer à mettre une
petite claque une petite gifle grosse
claque une grosse ziff en termes de
performances ça smartphones sur lequel
on a beaucoup de choses à dire alors
préparez vous parce que ça va y aller on
parle dès maintenant mais juste avant
juste avant je sais pas si vous êtes
déjà abonné à la chaîne et si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas je vous invite à le
faire en ayant cliqué sur le bouton vous
avez jusqu'ici en dessous
pourquoi parce qu'effectivement je
présente toutes les nouveautés
smartphone vous présente tous les
nouveaux concepts nouveaux smartphones
etc etc terme et pas que des smartphones
des monts des tablettes désordre et je
vous parle également de votre vie
numérique je donne des bonnes astuces
des bons conseils pour optimiser tout ça
donc si ce n'est pas déjà le gage invite
à vous abonner vous cliquez là vous
accédez à cloches comme ça vous saurez
tout et vous serez notifié et dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera prenait faisant
faire un tour du côté de la boîte j'aime
toujours le parti pris qui fait pas
l'astuce la tude nous propose quelque
chose de très particulier avec des
formes qui n'appartiennent qu'à eux
gardez vous l'ouvrez comme s'attaque
délicatement vous retrouver ici votre
smartphone alors moi j'ai déjà enlevé il
n'est plus là et ensuite à l'intérieur
de la boîte vous avez déjà ici un
accessoire c'est le ventilateur qui
fournit avec alors le ventilateur il est
intéressant courant point vous allez
pouvoir venir le positionner en dessous
votre smartphone et profiter ici d'une
prise jack
parce que voilà la bête et sur le
smartphone vous n'avez absolument aucune
prise jack et l'explication de m'adonner
asus là dessus c'est que en termes de
composantes ce que vous avez intérieur
vous n'avez absolument pas la place pour
venir mettre une prise jack des choix
ont été faits et si vous voulez donc une
prise jack vous ôtez la petite partie
vous avez là vous venez brancher votre
ventilateur j'ai pas encore enlevé le
plastique ne vous aurez votre plastique
vous prenez vous le mettez comme ça et
ça vous permet d'avoir une prise jack en
dessous pour bien profiter d'une
expérience au casque le reste après
s'ouvre comme ça vous découvrez ici une
petite coque vous avez à l'intérieur de
quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes sim
des petits autocollants ne pas déranger
je joue vous lever
vous y retrouvez ici votre bloc de
charge j'adore le packaging qui est fait
par asus là dessus c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très très très
très bien fait très bien réfléchi et en
terme d'expérience en termes d'hommes
boxing c'est vraiment très très cool
voilà le rock fauntroy d'asus je sais
pas si ça vous saute aux yeux et si vous
connaissez leur iphone 2 mais vous avez
une grosse grosse différence c'est que
vous n'avez plus aspect cuivre et que
vous retrouviez au niveau de la façade
déjà au niveau des hauts parleurs mais
également au niveau du dos alors on
garde toujours le logo ici ce design qui
est très particulier à asus mais c'est
un smartphone qui est beaucoup plus
consensuel qui est beaucoup moins
connoté gaming c'est donc un smartphone
qui sera plus passe partout si vous
voulez un smartphone extrêmement
performant et vous voit une très très
bonne machine vous pouvez partir là
dessus et en le voyant vos amis à votre
travail n'importe où du repas tiens t'as
acheté un smartphone le gaming et dire
on tient d'acheter un smartphone un
grand smartphone parce que oui si c'est
un grand smartphone à smartphone qui est
lourd je vous le dis tout de suite il
fait 240 grammes c'est peut-être le
smartphone le plus lourd en tout cas un
des plus lourds de par les composants
que vous allez avoir à l'intérieur mais
si vous aviez ce smartphone vous
l'achetez pas pour rien vous l'achetez
et pour ce qu'il a dans le ventre et
sage et vous détailler dans quelques
instants je sais pas si c'est évident
mais là vous le voyez vous avez un petit
trou qui est percé ici c'est un micro
c'est le quatrième micro sim 4e chrono
ce que vous allez faire de la vidéo pour
capter vraiment le son de façade et
venir améliorer significativement
l'autre jour de vos enregistrements pas
toujours évident de s'en rendre compte
mais vous avez un dos et reese et qu'un
effet arc en ciel on a ici un dos qui
pourrait effectivement un peu les traces
de doigts mais bon ça ça me paraît quand
même pas anormal mais vous avez surtout
le logo rogge qui s'illumine à l'arrière
c'est un smartphone qui est un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement avec un écran qui
fait 6,59 poussée de la molette c'est du
full hd plus de 1340 par 1080 à 391
pixels par pouce avec un taux de
rafraîchissement vous pouvez monter
jusqu'à 144 hertz les smartphones cette
année sur le haut de gamme sur le très
haut de gamme monde en 120 hertz et
dernière c'était en 90 hertz la asus a
été encore plus loin
144 m qu'est ce que je vous conseille
quand même c'est devenir le maître en
switch automatique vous n'avez pas
forcément besoin de 144 hertz partout
surtout dans des grosses parties de
gimme ça viendra quand même économiser
la batterie de votre smartphone et au
niveau de l'écran vous avez une latence
de 1
millisecondes un ratio 19 points 5/9
c'est un écran sacrifier hdr 10 plus
avec un échantillonnage tactile de 270
hertz et une latence d'actifs de 25
millisecondes une luminosité maximale de
659 avec un pic 2010 un profil
colorimétrique 113% dci p3 avec un
deltae inférieure à 1
un écran qui certifie au niveau matériel
lutter contre la lumière bleue mais il
ya surtout un truc qui est vachement
intéressant que j'aimais déjà beaucoup
l'année dernière c'est qu'en façade ici
là vous avez des hauts parleurs haut
parleurs stéréo un quai situé juste ici
un qui est situé juste là vous avez une
optimisation audio qui fait en
partenariat avec d'irak qui vont offrir
une meilleure spatialisation c'est
extrêmement impressionnant parce que
vous avez le souk est vraiment directive
face à vous et ça c'est très très très
cool haut parleurs là haut parleurs la
leçon vous arrive en pleine phase aller
et vous avez une vraie belle
spécialisation lorsque vous jouez
notamment un jeu vous allez comprendre
si on vient tirer deux ans ici ou tirer
là vous vous rendez vraiment compte de
ce qui se passe autour de vous alors que
ce soit pour du gaming de visionnages
tandis multimédia c'est complètement
disais et si vous avez un casque sans
fil vous pouvez bien connecté en
bluetooth
cinq points autant vous dire que c'est
pratique vous avez toutes les options il
ya également un petit accessoire pour
venir le brancher en usb c'est avec la
prise jack trouve pas ça hyper hyper
adapté pour la cession de gaming l'aude
une fois de plus vous débranchez votre
petit ventilateur ça deviendra refroidir
votre smartphone vous pourrez avoir
directement votre prise jack dessous
c'est pratique c'est sympa ça marche
bien et ça c'est cool mais c'est pas
tout parce que clinique smartphones de
gaming dit performance est là et là vous
avez un truc est vraiment incroyable fin
d'année dernière est sorti le seul un
dragon 865 c'était le socle plus haut de
gamme de coin comme soc 5 g et là vous
retrouvez dans ce smartphone là en tout
cas le snapdragon 865 plus qui sera 10%
plus puissant que lui 865 côté graphique
on retrouve une adreno de 850 vous avez
le choix entre soit 12 soit 16 giga de
ram un lp ddr5 il faut comme ça vous
êtes 51 % plus rapide que la lp ddr4 x
et en france vous avez une seule version
niveau du stockage ses 1 500 12 giga de
stockage en ufs 3.1 qui est 15 % plus
rapide en lecture et l'écriture que lui
fs 3.0 et bien évidemment je pense que
vous en douterez kelly et 512 il ya de
stockage du bien
évidemment que c'est du stockage qui est
non extensible et il est un score qui
est absolument incroyable sur en tout 2
647 1591 qui vient tout simplement le
classer en tête du classement au dessus
du au pot find x2 pro avec un écart est
quand même significatif puisque le
finepix deux pros et à 609 1045 là on
est à 647 1591 je pense que le rock 23
des zus va être en haut du tableau
pendant bon moment et en terme
d'expérience on ira jouer à tous les
jeux jouets vous avez vraiment un truc
qui est très très très très très cool
vous avez de quoi faire sans aucun
problème
quelles que soient les jeux auxquels
vous allez jouer vous allez avoir un
smartphone qui va répondre et très bien
et je vous dis une fois de plus la
partie audio est vraiment hall de là la
partie audio est vraiment extrêmement
poule
et si vous aimez jouer c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui peut être fait pour
à noter pour la party gaming vous
retrouvez sur votre côté ici votre bien
gêner votre génie du jeu avec tous vos
paramètres peuvent choisir d'activer
désactiver les alertes verrouiller la
luminosité faisait pas mal de
possibilités au poignet régler en plus
ici vos airs trigger très très
facilement qui se trouve ici
sur le dessus vous allez pouvoir
utiliser lorsque vous allez venir jouer
à vous les paramètres et comme vous le
souhaitez il est la nouveauté du côté
des airs trigger avec différents
mouvements par exemple vous allez faire
un swipe de l'extérieur vers l'intérieur
et ça vous fera un mouvement qui est
différent que si vous allez faire un
swipe de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur
vous avez donc deux mouvements
différents une personnalisation des dons
pouvoir aller plus loin dans vos jeux
vous pouvez venir enregistrer votre
écran vous avez beaucoup de paramètres y
compris la fréquence de votre processeur
qui tourne ici à 3,09 giga hertz la
température du smartphone voyait soit
passé très très cool le mode x activé
mais c'est un smartphone qui chauffe un
peu je vous le cache pas ici là la
partie là elle chauffe et on le sent
vraiment alors après lorsque vous allez
jouer en hiver et bien ça va vous tenir
chaud mais bon ce que je vous conseille
quand même si vous faire des grandes
parties gimme sévir brancher votre
ventilateur en dessous ça va aider à
dissiper la chaleur le juste rock funk
trop avec un smartphone qui a une très
grosse batterie
comme le asus rog phone c'est la même
chose une batterie de 6000 milles et en
terreur vous avez de laroche charge
rapide 30 watts c'est exactement la même
chose par rapport au modèle de l'année
dernière la différence et vous avez une
optimisation du flux de l'énergie qui a
amélioré de 30 % qui vous permettra de
le recharger malgré tout plus rapidement
et vous avez en tout pas moins de trois
modes de charges différentes le premier
c'est un mode de charge
lorsqu on appellera le slow charging qui
va vous rechargez vraiment tout
doucement c'est pas là vous allez le
plus net à l'avenir éviter de stresser
votre batterie et qu'à terme elle ne
sans dommage le deuxième mode ce qu'on
appelle le smart charging qui va venir
se régler par rapport à l'heure de
réveil de votre smartphone si par
exemple vous dit
ben tiens je vais me lever à 5h le matin
vous mettez votre réveil dans le
smartphone à cette heure et bien lui le
saura il connaît la durée de charge dont
il a besoin et il va revenir le chargé
pour qu'à cette heure il soit chargé dé
pâques qui commencent à se charger le
soir vous charge à fond sur des charges
en plus la nuit recharge
il vous fasse des petits va et vient ce
qui globalement n'est pas très très bon
envol ce matin d'ailleurs j'ai déjà
parlé de ça dans une vidéo je vous
invite à aller la visionner comme ça
vous saurez tout et on un troisième mode
qui est là pour préserver la durée de
vie de la batterie également donc autant
vous dire que vous avez de quoi faire en
termes de charge intelligente pour votre
smartphone et si vous avez besoin de le
recharger rapidement dû mettre un petit
complément à bien avec le chargeur 30
watts inclus ça ira parfaitement bien
cotés au s en a ici deux options ici on
tourne sur rangueil basé sur un android
dit mais s'il voulait quelque chose de
plus consensuel vous pouvez passer sur
zen et vous n'êtes plus du tout dans
l'idée des icônes gaming vous allez voir
quelque chose qui est comme je vous le
dis un peu plus consensuel mais qui
marchera aussi très très bien
personnellement je préfère le côté
gaming et c'est tout de suite beaucoup
plus racée potes me retrouve ici c'est
armorique wright vous appuyer là et vous
rentrez dans l'univers du gaming de ce
smartphone alors vous avez tous vos jeux
vous allez pouvoir retrouver ici voir
auquel vous avez envie de jouer voilà
vous avez tout votre lycée très très
cool bibliothèque de jeux vous avez
votre console sur votre smartphone
toutes les informations modique
s'activer mode x désactiver donne aussi
un smartphone qui fait la part belle à
la photo ça c'est plutôt bien puisque
vous retrouvez un grand-angle de 64
mégapixels c'est la fameuse sony mx 686
qui vous permettra alors à technologie
cas de pics allant d'un bref 1.8 vous
avez un ultra grand-angle de 13
mégapixels avec un champ de vision de
125 degrés qui ouvre à f 2.4 et vous
avez une petite caméra macro qui est
planqué ici sur le côté de 5 mégapixels
qui ouvre f
point zéro je vous montre le résultat
dans quelques instants tandis que vous
avez juste il s'est caché dans ce petit
coin une caméra selphy de 24 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.0
la partie software est plutôt cool je
passais sur l'ultra grand angle là vous
pouvez venir zoomer jusqu'à un zoom x 8
votre portrait panorama nuit manuel la
macro que vous retrouvez ici travail de
temps pro vidéo si vous souhaitez aller
beaucoup plus loin
vous avez aussi une stabilisation
électronique vous avez votre petit but
mettre en fonction pour capter le son
extérieur donc ça peut être pourquoi pas
mal si vous voulez film et on va
stabiliser vous filmez soit en full hd
soit en hd et si vous enlevez ça vous
pouvez monter jusqu'en 8 k oui je dis
bien huit cas à 30 images par secondes
sinon vous avez la 4k à 60 images par
seconde à vous de voir ce que vous
voulez voilà le résultat photos qu'on va
obtenir avec une autre asus troc
fauntroy on est sur la caméra principale
ce capteur sony fonctionne
merveilleusement bien une fois de plus
ici on a des résultats qui sont très
qualitatif on passe sur l'ultra grand
angle on perd un peu en précision mais
c'est pas anormal et des cons et se
rapprocher zoomer en fois de l on reste
effectivement sur le capteur principal
on vient vous met dans l'image sur un
foie de ça ira et des convient zoom est
beaucoup plus on perd forcément qualité
caméra principale soit on fait les mêmes
avec un contre jour on vient le chercher
avec l' ultra grand-angle ça
fonctionnera même si c'est pas là-dessus
combine le meilleur résultat de près
dans cette condition avec le soleil de
face on vient se rapprocher on vient
nous met en face d'eux ça ira à peu près
on voit un peu effectivement qu ici on a
un côté qui est un peu moins précis et
des conjointes davantage
on n'y est pas caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle une fois de plus la
colorimétrie est quand même très très
très proche entre les deux capteurs ça
fonctionne très bien et ça c'est bien
foi de ça fonctionne caméra principale
est ultra grand-angle ça fonctionne x 2
généralement je suis pas fan de la macro
c'est une grosse tendance tous les
constructeurs nos maîtres de la macro
par tous j'aurais préféré qu'on ait un
téléobjectif
ça aurait été mieux on aura fait plus de
choses avec cela coûtait plus cher
intégré ducourneau mais de la macro je
sais pas s'il ya eu des lots chez les
fournisseurs et les fabricants mais
foyer c'est pas gg alors il ya un petit
effet un peu rigolo on dise comme y
ajouter entre 4 à 6 cm pour moi n'est
pas réellement sur la macro j'ai du mal
à faire mon point à trouver la bonne
distance
après il ya les faits un plus rigolo
mais qui pour moi ne sert pas à
grand-chose voyez la forme et j'ai pas
réussi à l'avoir en sont complètement
net
résultat pour moi il est pas terrible la
caméra tlf et fonctionne celle taf
plutôt bien je suis en plein soleil est
là que je passe de l'autre côté à
l'ombre mais bien le résultat est somme
toute assez correct le mode portrait
fonctionne pas trop mal dans beaucoup de
performance derrière avec le stade
rigaud 865 plus donc le calcul se fait
très bien
il ya un côté un peu lisse et au niveau
du visage
néanmoins par contre ce qui marche très
bien c'est boyer là tout le découpage
qui est fait ici au niveau des cheveux
est très juste très bien fait et la
oumma toute la puissance de calcul de ce
socle mais la revue stroke fans trop est
également un smartphone qui a dû au wifi
si vous avez la possibilité de mettre
une double carte sim dans les deux cas
singulier puisque oui vous le savez pas
vous savez je sais pas mais peut-être
vous le savez de riom dit que l'émoi en
bas en commentaire le snapdragon 865 et
les 865 plus également ce sont des soc 5
j'ai donc là-dessus poème est de 4 à nos
sims un budget sans aucun problème vous
avez bien évidemment du nfc notamment
pour google paie vous n'avez pas par
contre ici de certification ip67 68 non
à cause du refroidissement les
smartphones gaming c'est la même chose
les besoins que les rangs d'un côté
ressorte de l'autre autant vous dire
étanchéité vous n'avez pas leur rassurez
vous si vous êtes dehors qu'il commence
à pleuvoir
eh bien ça ne craint pas pour votre
smartphone il est quand même
relativement protégé de ce côté là ne
n'étais pas dans un verre d'eau ou ne
mettait pas dans une piscine n'allez pas
vous baigner avec quelqu'un vous risquez
réellement de l'endommager et on en plus
un système intelligent d'agrégation des
données ça veut dire qu'il va venir
switcher intelligemment entre votre
connexion huit filles votre 4g votre 5g
pourquoi pas pour avoir toujours la
meilleure vitesse de connexion si votre
wifi et fonctionne moins bien si vous
avez une perte de vitesse une perte de
connexion et bien vous n'allez pas vous
en rendre compte ça va être transparent
sur laquelle jabbar revenir dessus sur
le wifi ci-après vous avez un meilleur
débit et ça de façon complètement
transparente également aux smartphones
qui est google stadia rebbie vous allez
donc pouvoir avec votre compte google
stade ya joué directement dans votre
smartphone vous n'utiliserez plus le
hardware de votre machine vous serez
dans le code mais si vous voulez le
faire tout cas ici vous pourrez faire et
il faut savoir qu'en achetant ce
smartphone vous avez trois mois de
google stadio faire tout ça c'est très
cool qu'est ce que je pense de tout ça
d'ailleurs ce que ça vaut pour venir
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire moi je pense qu'une fois de
plus
asus nous a sorti une vraie bête de
compet c'est clair la performance est là
l'autonomie
là on est sur une machine qui est
vraiment excellente pour le côté
multimédia au delà même de gaming si
vous voulez regarder des films des
séries vous voulez regarder comme ça
avec les hauts parleurs en façade le son
est très bien et claire alors on reste
sur deux parieurs de smartphones c'est
pas non plus de la magie mais ça marche
très très très très bien le fait de
pouvoir l'utiliser avec un casque sans
fil marchera une fois de plus
merveilleusement bien
on peut regretter mais sur les
smartphones très haut de gamme c'est pas
anormal de ne pas avoir de prise jack
binion - le fait pour avoir avec le
petit module ventilateur qui inclut sa
un vrai sens et notamment pour le gaming
moi j'aime bien je trouve performant on
a beaucoup de stockage c'est vraiment
une très très belle bête la photo
fonctionne bien mais c'est pas un
smartphone qui va venir acheter pour
faire de la photo néanmoins avec la
caméra principale vous ferez de bonnes
photos après on vient d'acheter ce
smartphone parce qu'on veut un
smartphone de gaming parce qu'on aime ça
attention - vous avez quand même des
grandes bord durant aux grandes banques
durant bac ce qui laisse la place
effectivement haut parleurs on n'est pas
sûr du bord à bord ici mais c'est pas
non plus qu'on vient chercher je trouve
qu une fois de plus asus a fait un très
bon smartphone très performant il
s'adresse vraiment aujourd'hui toujours
un public de gamers mais un petit peu
moins qui vient s'ouvrir davantage sur
une cible un peu plus large
personnellement j'aime beaucoup la juste
rothen 3 le truc qui est vraiment
important c'est qu'on a exactement le
même format exactement la même taille
d'écran que l'asus rog fun 2 parce que
si vous aviez l'asus rog fun ii et bien
les accessoires sont sans qu'on s'en
compatibles et ça c'est vraiment dire
alors qu en est il du prix on est sur un
smartphone qui écoute en version 12 igad
ram 512 go de stockage 999 euros en
version 16 giga de ram 512 giga de
stockage 1099 euros alors forcément on
va être plus cher que ce qu'on avait sur
la génération précédente déjà ne serait
ce que le fait d'avoir le stade ragone
865 + 5 g coûte plus cher la 5g coûte
plus cher et vous avez vraiment tout ce
qui va bien à l'intérieur a voulu venir
vous maintenant comment vous le trouvez
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous aviez déjà acheté un
smartphone de asus est ce que vous avez
acheté l'europe faune l'europe en deux
et est ce que vous pourriez vous tentez
sur l'europe 23 mar qui m'a tout ça bien
évidemment on va en commentaire quant à
nous on reste connectés
parce qu'à plein de choses qui arrivent
la taxe ne s'arrête jamais sur ce
jugement brasse monde allait enfin
bisous ça fait longtemps qu'on peut
s'endetter parce que je sais qu'avec
cette période actuelle qu'un peu
compliqué kovy des compagnies ballet
vision peut pas trop se faire mais nous
grâce à une petite caméra on peut
s'embrasser sans problème prenez soin de
vous
sa trémie
[Musique]
voilà ça
c